the joe rogan experience this is batch
two
uh which has like a big dark chocolate
note to it and
like a little cherry finish how do you
make a dark chocolate cherry finished
note
well for what the ingredients is i'm not
smelling any chocolate i don't taste any
chocolate you know
you don't taste chocolate i smell the
smoke for sure oh for sure but
leave your nose in it i can smell that
dark chocolate element that more bitter
side of things
i think i'm too stupid for that stuff no
i just think it's about
like when people do like when they do
wine i've been to a wine shop before and
they swim around like this is um
i'm very oaky i taste the tannins and
i'm like
well here's the thing is thinking so one
of one of the people a part of this
company uh
cat she's a whiskey sommelier so when i
when we asked for notes from her i'm
like oh
[ __ ] i am just blown away about all this
stuff and i'll smell like
yeah i get yeah i can kind of see i can
see that oh you're
right there yeah exactly but uh uh
but ultimately you got to just like it
you know you smell what you smell you
relate it to the things that you can
relate it to
working at restaurants for a long time
we had to do wine tastings and one of
the times the
the note they told us to look for was
cat piss
in the wine and i've never forgotten i
think about it every time someone
mentions it
that's an ohio thing bro i'm sure
someone's gonna do it yeah that's it
it's a high quality pure grade cat piss
right here flavor of it i mean
i'll just smell the ammonia i have no
idea but like oh it's stuck on the
internet that is the number one problem
with having cats man they [ __ ] piss
if you don't clean the box they'll piss
in your couch i've never had a cat that
lived indoors
really never no i oh my god my cats
always go outdoors
those are murderers i know cats that go
outside are the most
ruthless [ __ ] animals and that that's
the only kind of cat i've ever had they
are responsible for
in the bees billions people don't
know this if they have cats and
they think the cats are cute and they're
adorable they're they are adorable
but they're responsible for billions of
mammals and billions of birds in the
united states
every year believe it or not cat's pee
is an aroma
[ __ ] a high quality sauvignon blanc
funky and tangy smell if you're a cat
person
can be eerily similar to another odor
which you find often come in contact
wow how okay let's say it does have a
cat pee
note how is that going to encourage
people to want to drink it
what are you in the mood for you know i
think cat pee would go with this steak
right now
cat's pee tim aiken master of wine
scatological tasting terms or
comparatively
great burgundy smells of [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] man
it's very weird it's very it gets really
weird that's how you know you've lost
the plot like you got
so far that somebody goes you know what
how do i [ __ ] i'm just sound like
everybody else right now how do i turn
this up a notch
you know what i'm looking for this this
smells like
specific like bangkok street food
diarrhea
very spicy this smells like uh you know
a week-old yeast infection i'm looking
at a port-a-potty
from the 80s at a guns n roses concert
it smells like uh this smells like a pay
phone that's been in
uh um uh uh skid row in l.a for the last
10 years
pay phones those used to be a thing i do
have a description though
so i'm we're in china me and this
fighter alyssa
and i got alyssa uh uh this fight
in in china prior to this whole tour i
had set up
um so um uh alyssa garcia is a
105 pound fighter of mine but i got her
this fight at 1 15 in china
then i was shipping her to go train with
uh
um santiago his thai boxing gym miss
john wayne parks coach
and then she was going to then fly back
to tokyo finish her camp i was going to
meet her and then she fights in ryzen or
no she fought
in deep so we're over there and we're
being taken out
to this big fancy dinner ahead of the
event
and the promoters there were in shanghai
it's all this big deal at this private
room
and i'm like yeah you know i had some
chinese wine once it was was awesome you
know i'm down to drink whatever you guys
want to drink he's like i got the best
stuff for you you just wait
all right [ __ ] yeah so we got these tiny
little glasses
and what they're pouring in it is this
stuff called uh baiju there's chinese
wine
and uh or this chinese fermented uh
liquor
and i'm like oh well that's that's got a
nose on it and i i
i drink it i'm just like
and i but it's the kind of thing that
this is probably a pretty is a real
expensive one they're telling me and
they just keep pouring ones
and at some point alyssa goes dude i can
smell that [ __ ] from here
why do you keep drinking i go do you
think i'm gonna be the guy
to turn over and be like yeah this sucks
i hate it you know uh two on your
[ __ ]
fancy want your fancy booze and she goes
what does it taste like
i go okay this tastes like an old
abandoned home
that is being rained on for years
and what you've done now is all this
water has leaked through onto the
floorboards these dirty floorboards have
been
pissed on and dead cats are on all this
kind of stuff and it's all gone through
these floorboards
and then it's and this water has been
collected and it's been filtered out
through a hobo's
sock you know that's what this [ __ ]
tastes like and she goes what the [ __ ]
man i got
you want one she's like why would i ever
do that i know what it's like i would
take it
for me one of them babies oh how do we
get that stuff here oh it's here
it's here you can buy it you want me to
bring some we're gonna we're gonna drink
some baiju together
oh man next time we're gonna we're gonna
set it up
i need to know oh man it is it'll
probably happen in texas it's brutal
i've heard people describe it as it
tastes like something you run you like
clean a carburetor with
uh it's it's fermented
sorghum and other stuff